le bret bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france
rafael correa a donc été condamné à huit
ans de prison cassation pour corruption
il dénonçait un complot du président
équatorien actuelle any more heroes
selon vous cette décision de justice est
elle justifiée ou est ce une décision
politique
mais il ya beaucoup de zones d'ombré
dans cette affaire et je pense que cette
décision d'une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
démocratie équatorienne et latino
américaines
c'est ce qui confirme un peu ce qu'il se
passe en amérique latine depuis
plusieurs mois voire depuis plusieurs
années on s'était un peu le même schéma
de ce qui s'était passé au brésil un
camp nou il avait été condamné et
emprisonné quelques temps avant
l'élection présidentielle
donc oui c'est à mon avis une
utilisation du pouvoir judiciaire comme
arme politique
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'avait déclaré
interpol en rejetant la lame rouge qui
avait donné le président lenin moreno
contre parfait il court et à interpol
avait dit rafael correa victime de
persécution politique
d'ailleurs le groupe de puebla aussi a
notamment qui rassemble des forces
progressistes de gauche et en amérique
latine a déclaré a exprimé son
inquiétude non seulement pour cent par
rapport à rafael correa mais aussi par
rapport à ses partisans à d'ancien
sénateur d'anciens parlementaires
rafael correa dit adieu à ses espoirs de
vice présidence puisqu'il y avait prévu
d'être coalition février prochain cet
essai au dc set et elle le moyen
justement au d'évincer l'ancien
président des prochaines élections
générales
bienvenue l'ondé clair les gouvernements
de l'éliminer de dénigrer nos parlant
des cartes est justement rafael correa
mais aussi ses partisans je pense que il
ya deux mois il avait essayé de
suspendre plusieurs partis politiques
d'opposition pour les prochaines et les
échéances électorales de février
prochain mais ce qui serait bien de
rappeler c'est un peu le le contexte
finalement qu'est ce que représente la
nuit moreno il représente le retour des
politiques d'austérité néolibérale il
représente le retour de les familles qui
affaiblit d'état alors qu'on a beau
soit en amérique latine et en équateur
notamment d'un rôle d'états de l'état
très fort pour protéger les populations
surtout dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire actuelle c'est le retour aussi
d'un alignement vis-à-vis de la
politique étrangère des états unis
donald trump
c'est aussi une augmentation de la
pauvreté
on est passé de 34% à la fin du mandat
de rafael correa
à 38 ans on arrive presque à 40 % non
une augmentation de 6% à poireauter donc
ces vieilles recettes néolibérales ne
fonctionne pas en amérique latine
elles affaiblissent l'état et dans un
contexte de fracture sociale
insoutenable la défense peut encore
déposer un recours rafael correa peut-il
encore espérer un renversement de
situation selon vous pour l'heure ça
serait une décision importante
moi je pense que tant que les lignes
renault sera de pouvoir
l'avis de rappel courriers au départ
rappelle coréen de la vider de ses
militants de ses partisans en équateur
et en danger je pense que la communauté
internationale doit réagir
on a vu ces mêmes expériences au brésil
en argentine
enfin sous le mandat de mauricio macri
et là il ya quelques instants on a
appris que evo morales pareillement il a
été suspendu pour être candidat au sénat
dont il ya vraiment une volonté de la
droite
l'ate numérique n des cartes et des
forces politiques de gauche aux
échéances électorales
et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
démocratie dans le continent merci
beaucoup
pierre lebret d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je vous rappelle que vous êtes
politologue spécialiste de l'amérique
latine